as pacific island nations slowly emerge
from the covert 19 pandemic a new
diplomatic battle is underway and china
is on the offensive rebuilding the
region's economies will take time and
outside assistance and beijing is
extending a helping hand
don't be too anxious and don't be too
nervous because the common development
and prosperity of china and all the
other developing countries would only
mean greater harmony greater justice and
greater progress of the whole world
the latest stop on chinese foreign
minister wang yi's 10-day tour of the
pacific was fiji where he met prime
minister frank bani marama
geo-political point scoring
means less than little to anyone whose
community is sleeping beneath the rising
seas
whose job
has been lost to a pandemic or whose
family
is impacted by the rapid rise in the
price of commodities
the main feature of his visit to suva
was supposed to be the signing of an
agreement with foreign ministers from 10
countries but it didn't happen the
so-called common development vision
outlines wide-ranging plans to improve
relations between china and the island
nations including increased cooperation
on security last month beijing signed a
security pact with the solomon islands
that some observers say may lead to a
permanent chinese military presence
there
this vast region again finds itself
caught in the middle of a much wider
struggle for power and influence at the
moment being courted economically isn't
a bad situation for these countries to
be in but the area's strategic
importance has many worried that that
struggle could be taken to a dangerous
new level
the pacific nations are also on the
front lines of climate change and that's
been a future of the foreign minister's
tour
many countries here are at risk from
rising sea levels and there's a sense
their concerns haven't been taken
seriously enough by regional powers
australia and new zealand despite that
experts say fiji in particular isn't
going to sign any agreements that will
harm relations with its allies
fiji doesn't want to have i think
too much dependence on any one country
and it's it's very i think important for
fiji to have good relationships with all
the major powers
may not have secured the regional deal
he was hoping for but the chinese will
be taking a long-term view of their
pacific relationships this has been a
highly visible tour so far and that in
itself may be viewed as a success wayne
hey al jazeera suva fiji